and that's when uh Tristan de monabell
walked into my Toast Masters Club and
little did I know that he was on a
mission to uh learn a new skill as fast
as possible in order to be featured
hopefully in Scott Young's book Ultra
learning cuz Scott young was looking for
guinea pigs of like who are people that
can learn a skill in the fastest amount
of time and Achieve extraordinary
results no way yeah so he was recruited
how did that work was he like hired to
go like no no no not like that he was
just uh one of Scott's readers and I
think Scott put out like a blog post of
like I'm looking for interesting people
to take on learning projects and
depending on how the success of your
project you might be featured in my book
type of thing interesting and so for
like a reference one of the people in
Scott's book Ultra learning is uh is the
world champion of French Scrabble so it
was the person who won the World
Championships in French Scrabble and I
think at the start of the project the
person didn't speak
French
yeah so was he did he succeed in making
it into the book Tristan yeah he's all
of chapter 3 really yeah yeah no way I
just was talking to Scott about his next
book which is get better at anything um
so we're going to be helping him get the
word out about that that's such a this
world is so small so funny yeah
interesting so he he was there did he
have a pre-existing interest in public
speaking or he no he was actually going
to do piano that was the skill he was
going to choose to ultra learn but he
was already a guitarist and had a guitar
course and Scott suggested like you know
or maybe it was a different friend that
suggested that's like you know it's too
similar of a skill it might not be
impressive from the outside if you
succeed in that um and then a different
friend said uh you know if you're going
to do a project that this intensive you
should really learn a meta skill meaning
like a skill that can feed into all
areas of your life and improve
everything it's a great advice it was
really good advice and so Tristan chose
public speaking he walked into my toast
Master's club uh his version of the
story which I love is he saw me speak
and do one of these table topics and he
was very impressed by like the ability
to just he also thought I prepared
something and someone told him like oh
no no no this is all on the Fly wow so
was like I want to be coached by that
guy which was really flattering we
started I started being his mentor but
very quickly he discovered that there's
this contest called The World
Championships of public speaking it's
held by Toast Masters every year there's
like 30,000 people who compete every
year and Tristan thought like oh this is
great there's like it's like little
league there's area contest division
contest District contest there's all
these levels and you get eliminated
everyone gets eliminated except the
winner and he's like this is a perfect
ladder or or structure for my learning
project and so I started coaching him he
signed up for this contest he had to
qualify by giving six speeches because
you couldn't participate in the contest
if you didn't give six qualified
speeches but the contest was starting in
two weeks and usually people give six
speeches in like two three four months
so Tristan like accelerated contacted
all these clubs across La just to get
his six speeches in and by the time he
participated in his first round
contest uh I already knew that like wow
this guy is willing to do a lot just to
just to achieve his his goal what made
him so motivated it couldn't couldn't
have been just to be featured in this
book and was he working during this time
or was this like a full-time Pursuit so
he had a business called about the start
and I think it's he still has it but
it's it's more on the side now it's um
teaching guitar
Independence um but about the start was
the the company itself was about how do
you teach adult to learn new skills fast
so that was always his passion he's the
type of guy who like picks up juggling
in a day picks up surfing in a day like
he's a he's a real strategic learner and
he's kind of obsessive about learning
and so I think he wanted
to um I think he wanted to in service of
that business um with the Serendipity of
Scott and with just more of a of a
spaciousness in his schedule I think
everything coalesced to take on a real
learning project and he was going to
blog about his whole experience and
everything um so he chose public
speaking and he found this contest and
he signed up and we met and um the
contest lasts for seven months so if you
keep winning and so he won the contest
at the club level and then we started
refining the speech and then he won at
the the division level or the area level
and every step of the way we're like
watching Finding Nemo and trying to pick
up storytelling techniques we'd watch
like Fight Club and we'd go whoa like
there's this twist how do we add a Twist
to the speech and we'd break down all
the world champion speeches and study
like how are they using the stage so it
was a real deep dive into storytelling
into public speaking into we spoke to
movie directors and they would review
the script so it was a real real
strategic focused project and he just
kept winning and winning and winning and
by the time it was like 4 months in uh
he qualified for the semifinals which is
like the top 100 in the world and um we
had three months to write a second
speech that he would give on the stage
so so you were writing partners and then
he was delivering the talks I'd say for
the first three months um I was more the
writing coach if anything um but it was
more like the storytelling coach like oh
there seems to be
one of the biggest insights we had from
the world championship Journey was the
need for the mentor
character we would create these s minute
speeches these beautiful stories and
they wouldn't resonate with the
audience something was missing and we'd
collect feedback and over time we saw
like oh all of the life lessons in this
story all of the wisdom the message of
the story is coming from Tristan that's
the problem people don't want to
hear you be the hero they want to hear
the mentor be the hero you're the main
character you're just like me
interesting and so we're like oh yeah so
in Star Wars there's the Yoda character
in Karate Kid there's Mr Miyagi like
there's always a mentor character That's
The Giver of advice and so we're like
all right the story is missing something
so we changed the whole story and we uh
we ended up remember or Tristan
remembered like oh yeah his grandmother
was like a very pivotal person person in
his life and so we actually centered the
story around her influence in his life
and she was this like motorcycle riding
grma you know those things like that
that we discovered through the process
you treated it like a science like a
almost like a product development
process I guess you itated you refined I
don't think most people think of
speaking that way at all and and they
shouldn't let me be very clear this was
a this was a science project and it was
for a contest so it's kind of like if
you're going to commit to winning a
contest you got to study the contest
rules you got to understand what the
judges are judging on you got to break
down what this thing is what we learned
and I want to come back to this is that
like the contest is not the real world
how you win the contest is not how you
become a fantastic speaker but there are
certain elements of Storytelling and
public speaking that do transfer so yeah
we really obsessed over the contest but
I I do want to tell you one one story
Tristan had this uncanny ability to do
more than what everyone else would do so
typically a toast Master's people would
give a speech once a week at their Toast
Masters Club Tristan hired a virtual
assistant and said I want you to find me
all the Toast Masters in the Los Angeles
area I want you to contact them for me
and I want you to schedule a speech for
me every single day so every day I want
to have a speech
scheduled so what we'd do is he'd meet
me at 6:00 a.m. before I started work
and we'd have this piece of paper and we
try to make a draft as far as we could
by 8:00 a.m. I had to go to work we'd
have this incomplete draft and there's
gaps in it and I was like all right
Tristan you got to fill in the gaps in
the moment he dried to like Long Beach
to go to Long Beach Toastmaster show up
with this Half Baked script
stepped on stage improvised his speech
unbeliev filmed it all on camera got
feedback from every audience member came
back home reviewed it and the next
morning at 8:00 a.m. we'd go over the
footage we'd go over the feedback we'd
start working on the script what might
be missing what character what motifs
might be missing okay he's got to go
he's got another speech lined up in
Torrance and so he did this wait a
different speech or the same speech that
he's refining the same speech that he's
refining but the spe the refining of a
speech is not linear it's like one day
it's a story about the grandmother the
next day it's like no let's actually
make it about how how you met your wife
it's like oh no actually this scene
doesn't work we need to find a totally
different character a totally different
plot line so the speech is going in all
sorts of directions as we try to figure
out like what's going to resonate with
the audience what's also true to
ourselves but every day Tristan is
taking these half-baked progress ideas
showing up and doing it live and just
some of them are just like brutal like
it's cringy to watch for me I can't
imagine what it's like for him cuz he's
just like doing his best to put it all
on the fly in the moment but he's just
so relentless for the pursuit of of
feedback that he would do it he'd
collect the feedback we'd study it the
next day and incrementally over time the
pieces would start to connect and
eventually we'd have this the skeleton
of a speech and suddenly the feedback is
getting stronger and the the elements
are starting to click in and I would say
like if the average Toastmaster gave
like a
speech two speeches a month that's on
the higher side uh Tristan probably gave
like 20 to 30 a month and so he just
outworked everybody in the competition
same yeah so how did it turn out so we
reached the semi-finals um he went up on
the stage there were 10 competitors and
uh he decided to go you can choose you
have two speeches you can choose which
one you give he decided to go with uh uh
the weaker one the one we thought was
not as good and uh and he he gave the
speech and after him this contestant
goes up and they're walking up uh the
next contestant and he's blind and he
they roll out a carpet and they walk him
through and the first thing he shares in
his story is like when I was 6 years old
I remember the sound of chickens and I
look out through the kitchen window and
I see them and then all of a sudden
pitch
black and I've never been able to see
again and I'm sitting in the audience
going there's no way Tristan's going to
win this thing like the story is insane
but somehow uh and this is the hard
thing with speeches is like to keep an
audience's attention all the way through
for 7 minutes in an Engaged and raptured
way is hard
and so that contestant story had a dip
toward the middle and it never recovered
and so Tristan ended up winning the
semifinal and there's this photo of us
just I just like climbed on top of him
and we're hugging it's like so probably
the one of the best moments of of Our
Lives he got to the top 10 of the world
championship and he stood in front of
3,000 people and he gave his best speech
and uh he didn't win it was in that
experience and that moment that we knew
like first of all wow this was super fun
I think we should keep working together
and then second of all it was like I
feel like we should start teaching what
we've learned cuz we learned a whole
bunch